you need to create an environment of
Excellence most people's environments
are not excellent the people around you
the videos that you watch the things
that are on your wall the voices that
are in your head you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal improvements in their life year
over year and if you don't want to stay
where you are right now fast forward to
one year from today you don't want to
say stuck you want to be in a different
place it could actually be physically
moving but a different place in terms of
your finances in terms of your purpose
like today this is not acceptable
anymore I accept that this is where I am
right now but where I end up is not
going to be the same spot as where I am
right now the biggest shift that will
help you get from where you are now to
where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence need
motivation watch the top 10 or we
believe Nation hey seven Carmichael and
I make these videos because in my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that extra bit of belief
and I still need their stories today and
I'm honored to share them with you here
as well so today you get to learn from
me and my team's take on my top 10 rules
of success enjoy
what's the fastest way to learn a
language what's the fastest way to learn
Japanese well it's to go to Japan sure
you can read some books and and you can
hire a tutor and the more intense it
becomes the more you're actually living
it the faster you're gonna pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really matters so figure out how you
love to learn for me it's videos I like
to see things I need to be visual if
that's you then you need to have a way
to have those videos coming into your
life every day it can be part of your
morning routine that's why I make this
channel part of your morning routine
subscribe to the channel every morning
every weekday we got a new video out
there for you to give you the shot event
special to help you but if it's not my
channel it's some other channel one of
my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or this the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him rule number two is trust your
ideas I'm the kind of person who likes
to write things down I'm the I'm the
kind of person who has I want to have an
idea whether it's two in the morning or
or you know three at night or whatever
it is when I have an idea I want to
write it down I feel like unless I can
get it out of my head and now I tend to
just send myself an email right in
Evernote until I get it out of my head
I I'm unsettled I feel like I'm gonna
forget the idea and it's something that
I've wrestled with this message of
you know maybe I'm just not gonna write
anything down
and the best ideas that I have will just
continue to come back and come back and
come back and those are the ones that I
should run with and if I look at how
many times I actually look over that
Evernote file it's pretty slim
and I feel like I kind of do it anyway
where the best ideas come back to me
over and over again and that's what I
run with but I haven't fully embraced it
maybe it's out of fear of losing a great
idea and every now and then when I look
through the notes something does come
back and I end up running with it and I
fear that I may have forgotten if I
didn't write it down and I could have
missed a big chunk of a big project I'm
working on but maybe that's an
irrational fear I don't know this is
something that I want to play with more
I do know that when I was thinking about
my one word of believe that's been the
foundation for this Channel and a lot of
the you know work that I do when I first
thought about it I felt like it was too
big I felt like it wasn't the right one
for me I felt like uh I felt like it was
hard to live up to and the more I slept
on it the more time went on the more you
know I experimented with it the more it
felt right and every passing day
that big idea just stuck with me more
and more and more until I embraced it
fully and it became the basis of this
Channel and in my website and all the
work that I do
so I think there's something there I
feel like I don't do a good enough job
on it and I wonder if it might be worth
an experiment for a week
to not write anything down
and just trust that the Big Ideas will
stay there
that's an interesting one
I'm going to think on that I'm not going
to write it down
but I'm going to think on that rule
number three is be persistent most
people don't get what they want because
you don't follow through enough you just
don't follow through it's based out of
insecurity you start and stop start and
stop you're afraid of hurting people's
feelings you're afraid of what they're
gonna say about you you're afraid
they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume so we we stop we stop
and try to do something else where we're
seeing more immediate results but if
it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stories with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know you know
great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then he said
oh man thank you uh I'm super swamped
right now but uh let's see they're do
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
uh maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out maybe I'm
offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's he's just a busy guy he had a lot
of stuff going on he had a launch that
was happening that I wasn't even aware
of uh that he was planning behind the
scenes and so he is he was you know not
crazy stressed out but he just has a lot
on his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm gonna
send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and hopefully you know he doesn't think
I'm a loser or whatever
and he he wrote back an email and like
hey sorry man again I'm not super great
on email just been swamped planning all
these things uh yeah come on out come
out to the event speak at the event too
and that was his big event that was you
know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind to
be a part of that then I spoke on stage
that then at the event after I spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Louis house and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses
all of that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence rule number four is focus on
serving it's for imposter syndrome
honestly there's two things that I'll do
one is remember who you're focused on
serving right we're so worried about
trying to be someone that we're not and
who might judge us and who might comment
on your video or whatever it was
something nasty but focus on who you're
serving who you are serving like
somebody needs your message today you've
got a message you've been through
something you have advice to share
somebody needs that and focus on who
that person is and it may not be a
million people it may just be eight
people who watch your video but for one
person that might be a life like your
message might be the life-changing
message that they need today and so
focus on that when you're out there
creating and two the other thing I find
helpful is imagine you're talking to
younger you
so
when we get stuck in imposter syndrome
we think of oh if you look at Angela
who's hosting her own show like well but
I'm not Larry King or I'm not Oprah or
I'm not whoever and we let that be the
reason why we don't start
whereas think about who you used to be
so for me the most painful point in my
life was 19 when I quit on my business
partner and so I go back to think can I
help 19 year old Evan
if I was gonna sit on a park bench and
talk to 19 year 11 would I have
something that I could say and yeah of
course of course I could help I mean
that believe I can help a million people
but I believe I can help younger me and
same thing for you you may not feel like
you can help tons of people you have
imposter syndrome about that but if you
think back to who you used to be think
about who you were five years ago you
from five years ago would listen to you
today and they may not listen to Evan
Carmichael or Oprah or whoever but
they'll listen to you
and so
if you you can have a message for
younger you well there's millions of
people who currently are younger you and
they're struggling
and they need you
and just I don't know just the way that
that is framed
for me gets me out of my way
and forces me to get into action mode
they're both an angle of service you
know I'm always going to lean on service
one is you're thinking about the people
who you can help and two as you think
back to younger you and recognize that
you could help younger you and there are
millions of people right now who are
younger you
and they need your help
so it's time to go through also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is eliminate
negative thoughts that negative voice
inside your head that's telling you that
you suck and you can't do it that's not
your voice
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up
telling you that you can't do something
you were not born you didn't come out of
the womb and say I suck I can't do
anything no you're playing you're
experimenting you're finding Joy you're
laughing you're you're doing it
and then along the way people tell you
that you can't do it that you should
stop that you should quit that it's not
gonna work out that you can't do it and
we've been so conditioned around that
that we take it on and we think it's our
voice
when you come up with an idea right
just Workshop this you come up with an
idea and say oh I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna launch his
business I'm going to whatever you can
put your your bucket list your your
dream life your vision boards you come
with a list of ideas things that you
think that you want to do things that
you
feel confident that you'd love to create
for yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends you
know I think we we blame our friends and
say well we tell our friends and they're
going to be negative and and they they
they crap on our idea and so we don't do
it well before that happens we crap on
our own ideas right you look at that
list the next day and say I can't do
that who who
who was I yesterday's crazy person that
I used to be yesterday who thought I
could do that
it's ourselves telling ourselves that we
suck but the problem is we've taken on
that voice and we think that it's us
that's not your voice that is not your
voice telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there that we have taken on as our voice
it has become your identity but it was
not your voice it was put there it was a
seed that was planted that has been
grown over time and you need to rip that
weed out
that is not your voice
do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore hopefully that creates
an aha moment for you that starts to
actually shift things because we've been
so conditioned to listen to that voice
that we don't recognize that we actually
have a choice to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice
rule number six is don't quit it's only
a failure if you quit
it only counts as a failure if you stop
if you've got a big goal a big dream a
big ambition and you want to chase it
down and it doesn't work out on the
first try or the second try the third
try if you keep going eventually you'll
figure it out this is the path of all
successful entrepreneurs like if you
keep going you keep putting one foot in
front of the other eventually it will
work out is why a lot of entrepreneurs
will preach patience because most people
quit too soon most people they
overestimate what they can get done in a
short amount of time and underestimate
what they can get done over a long
amount of time and they just quit too
soon you don't allow enough time for
momentum to actually take hold and so
it's only really a failure if you stop
people ask me about about my videos and
my YouTube channel and there's a couple
angles on this the first is how long it
took me to get going if you look at my
uh my growth and my channel my home page
you can see how long it took me to get
going it took five years and I still had
seven thousand subscribers or something
like that and the only thing that I had
going for me was that I just did not
stop I I was introverted and shy I still
am I didn't know how to make videos that
was very uncomfortable in front of the
camera I was completely embarrassed by
my own stuff the first 350 videos I
couldn't watch back couldn't watch
myself back I was too critical on myself
too embarrassed that I was putting this
out
um too hard on myself that I that it
wasn't good enough and that I wasn't
delivering value and just nitpicking
myself so many times on the videos that
I I just couldn't watch them back 350
videos public videos on my channel
before I was not just completely
embarrassed by myself and then 700
before I inspired myself like oh you
know what I'm like that was pretty good
I have one that I'm happy with after 700
public videos
so most people just quit too soon the
only thing I had going for me I didn't
have the skills I didn't have the
personality I was not funny I didn't
have the editing capabilities I didn't
have the camera the technical
capabilities the only thing I had going
for me was that I kept going
I had the heart
I wanted to serve and I just kept going
I just kept creating I just kept making
and now we're here you know started from
the bottom now we're here that's now
we're here but it took a long time to
get going and most people who probably
have more
natural abilities
more camera presence more humor more fun
uh they could have been way ahead of me
not that it's a competition but they
could have had success
but they didn't because they stopped
they quit rule number seven is apply the
595 rule if you want a guaranteed way to
move into action apply the 595 rule
spend five percent of your time planning
and 95 of your time doing five percent
planning 95 doing most people are afraid
to apply the 595 rule because you're
afraid that you'll take the wrong action
that you'll make a mistake that it won't
be perfect but here's what's going to
happen while you are sitting there
planning your perfect next move someone
with less Talent with less skills than
you will win with a half-baked idea
because they applied the 595 Rule and
just got started and then don't think
about it just go off and do it
stop planning that's the plan the plan
is done stop planning now do rule number
eight is build Cornerstone habits and to
get really clear on what the Habit is
that you want to develop don't pick 20
different habits that you would want to
do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat well and
I'm gonna make content I'm gonna grow my
business I'm gonna find a girlfriend I'm
gonna like whatever the thing is you
come with 20 different habits that
you're gonna do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you started
has that happened and have you tried to
take on too much at once what is the
single most important habit that you
need to start to build that if you look
back in a year you could say I'm so
happy that I built this one habit
because it's helping you accomplish your
goals what is the most important habit
it could be waking up at a certain time
it could be taking care of your your
mind it could be taking care of your
body it could be putting in a certain
amount of work on your business it could
be right in your book it could be making
100 videos like what is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the Cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because it guarantee
listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too rule
number nine is join a community the
reason why you're not following through
is because you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely
but this is the life of an entrepreneur
this is why so many great entrepreneurs
don't follow through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it
but I have a really low maybe it's just
introverted or or uh whatever but I just
don't need it as much as most people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you
know you get to pick everything you want
but then to go from having a job where
you have Community even if it even if
you didn't enjoy the work you were doing
which you got from the job if you've had
one is community that you had co-workers
and you had some people who you did like
and you had people to go to lunch with
and you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
okay great yeah you just tore my heart
open Evan now what do I do how do I fix
it well first is just recognizing that
that is a problem you know first is
recognizing that there's nothing wrong
with you there's nothing wrong with you
you're amazing the only problem is you
just don't have anybody that you're
collaborating with that you're doing
this by yourself so the answer is we
need to now go and find other people to
collaborate with and Rule Number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is kick forward I think comparison
to other people is fantastic I think
most people just do it wrong I think
most people just do it wrong you look at
somebody else you see their life you see
what they're doing you see their
business see the success you see how old
they are as one of the common questions
people ask well how old are you well
typically it's because they want to they
want to judge their own progress against
yours
the comparison can be great but you have
to use it as a kick forward instead of a
kick down most people will kick
themselves down they realize that you
haven't you realize you haven't done
much you realize that you're not where
you want to be you realize all these
other people have done it with maybe
less resources than you at an earlier
age than you and you feel like it's over
and you can't do it that's a kick down
it's a comparison it's a kick down and
that's what most people do and that's
why there's so much advice out there
from people saying don't compare
yourself to others because when we do it
we typically kick ourselves down that's
the wrong way to do it the comparison to
other people
comes from knowing what's possible and
being inspired to want to go off and do
it
you know I just came back from a trip
with um my beach gang and it's
some big name people it's Brandenburg
Charlotte and Mel Robbins and uh Lewis
Howes and Jay Shetty and you know all
these all these big people who've done
big things
and we sit around the table
and we share and we help and it's our
own Mastermind it's not a paid thing
it's where they go and and we all share
and as they're talking as they're
sharing what they're up to and what
they're working towards
I'm thinking that's what's possible
that's what I could do if I wanted to
that's what that's how they're doing
their marketing okay if I could do this
and maybe they're three years ahead of
me but by learning their strategies I
can get there in six months
the comparison pushes you forward
runners run faster when there's somebody
next to them businesses innovate faster
when there's competition
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday is not enough of a push
forward that's the problem comparing
yourself to who you were yesterday is is
a great it's great for self-love
but it's not enough of a push
so I'd encourage you to start thinking
about an audit for yourself right now
if you're really low
if there's no self-love
if you don't feel like anything is
possible that's where you look back and
you look at the progress that's when you
look back and say where was I five years
ago where was I 10 years ago look at how
much you've grown and learned and
improved and how much in a better
situation you are compared to where you
used to be even if it's not financially
just mindset just mentally just the kind
of person you are how you treat people
you've probably grown if you're watching
this channel it means you're into
personal growth self-development
so whether it's from my videos or
somebody else's content you've been
learning and growing over the past five
years you've grown a lot you're not the
same person you used to be you're a lot
more proud of yourself than who you used
to be and whenever you're feeling low on
yourself that's when you look back and
track the progress that's when you look
back and see who you used to be and how
much you've grown and improved and
gotten better and that can
start to fill you up again
but when you're ready for growth
when you're ready for ambition when
you're ready for the next level
I think the comparison is fantastic
I think to know that something is
possible it's the whole Roger Bannister
four minute mile nobody thought it was
possible then Roger Bannister did it and
now everybody's doing it not everybody
but a lot of people did it why because
they were comparing themselves to him
because they know now that it's possible
and so when you see somebody else do it
when you see somebody else making
amazing things you don't have to default
to say I suck because they're doing it
and I'm not that's a kick down you can
choose
to use it as inspiration to say that's
what's possible
and if she can do it if he can do it
then so can I
and use that as the push to get you to
the next level
at our beach gang
last year
I got challenged a couple times I got
challenged by Brendan I got challenged
by Russell Brunson I got challenged by a
whole bunch of people and and I got
challenged without people even talking
to me sometimes just by them sharing
their story
I look at that and say I want to do that
not in the way that I suck and I can't
do it but no in a year I want to be
there in two years I want to be there in
five years I want to be there I want to
be there I want to be there I look at
young Les Brown I think he's the
greatest speaker of all time I don't
look at him and say
he's so much better than me he's got
this natural gift I suck I'm never going
to do it I look at him and I say I want
to be that good that's what's possible
it's an inspiration to move forward
so how do you make it tactical
there's a couple things that I think
would be helpful for you
one
look at some people who you respect
inside your industry or outside you're
interested it's just something that you
respect about them maybe it's me maybe
it's Jordan Peterson maybe it's Oprah
who are the people that you look up to
and respect what are the things so too
what are the things about them then that
you want to get better at if you respect
somebody's because they're they're ahead
of you
it's something that you want to be good
at
maybe it's in their business maybe it's
in their speaking maybe it's in their
relationships they've done something or
they're living a way that is ahead of
you
so what is that thing too what is that
thing what is the thing that they have
that you are aspiring to get better at
there's no one person who is the ideal
Mentor you don't want to be me you don't
want to be Jordan Peterson you don't
want to be Oprah
they have parts of their eye Parts in my
life that you don't want
the whole point is to take different
pieces from different people to make the
best you you want to for me I wanna be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs that's why
he's on my wall and I want to be a
father like my father was that's why
he's on my wall I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs was and I don't
want to be a Visionary like my dad
because they're not
so you're taking different people and
different things from them to help you
become the best you
so one is you're making a list of all
the people that you look up to that you
respect that there's something about
them that you you gravitate towards to
you find that specific thing I wanna I
Wanna Have Courage like this person I
want to have love like this person I
want to be a husband or or a wife like
this person right I want to be a mother
or father like this person that they're
the ideal to shoot towards and prove you
to make you want to strive to get better
and then three you dive into their story
you dive into their content you dive
into their videos their books their
podcasts their biographies you dive into
them on a consistent basis watching One
video is not enough it's a consistent
basis to help you start
to think like that
somebody asked me yesterday why do you
read so many books at a time I read
seven to ten books at a time I never
really thought about why I do it it just
seemed to work for me but as I dissect
it I love micro dosing on books I love
micro dosing on content because think
about what happens when you read a book
so one of the books I'm reading right
now is Jay shetty's think like a monk so
when you're reading Jay shetty's book it
it forces you to start thinking like a
mug it forces you to have more presence
and more gratitude and more mindfulness
and if you're going to read some
hardcore the other another book I'm
reading is 75 hard from Andy frizzella
which is in your face hardcore punching
you in the stomach you know yelling at
you let's go
two totally different Vibes I like both
I don't want a bj Shetty I don't want to
be any Priscilla
but I like the mindfulness and present
of of Jay Shetty and I like the
aggressiveness and push of Andy for sale
in in that combination is Evan
Carmichael
so why I read seven to ten books at a
time is because the micro dosing of the
books when you're reading a book if I
only read Jay shetty's book I've become
very mindful very very grateful very
present and then I put the book down and
they pick up a different book and then
what you start to do is lose
the train of thought you lose the thing
that you learn from Jay unless you're
picking up another Jay Shetty book but
he's only got one out right now
so instead instead of going hardcore and
just reading one book I like having Jay
Shetty once a week I like having any
fisella once a week I like in the videos
that I make to have different people we
have Jordan Peterson once a month and
Elon Musk once a month and Oprah once a
month because diving deep on one person
can be great
but what happens
on the ongoing I'm much more concerned
about the ongoing than I am about the
what's happening intense at the moment
because the ongoing is how you win
if you want to have success in anything
going going to the gym and working out
for four hours is not going to do much
for you but if you go to the gym every
day for half an hour you start to see
results
a bunch of stores in there but the main
concept is I think comparison is
fantastic you just have to use it
smartly when you look at somebody else
understand that you don't want their
entire life
you don't want their entire life
but there's something about them that
they're better than you at and use that
as inspiration for you to get better
instead of you telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it
comparison will push you forward
comparison will help you get the life
that you want as long as you're kicking
yourself forward not down
the difference between a great day and a
mediocre one
is your intention
how did you decide to show up today most
people have no intention most people you
wake up you check your phone you're
falling into other people's emergencies
other people's demands and your time
what everybody else wants for you to do
today right everybody's got an agenda
everybody's got an opinion on what you
should do with your life you open your
phone there's all sorts of other
people's emergencies for what you should
be doing right their emergencies become
your priorities because you don't have
intention in the day where when you flip
it when you start to say no I am going
to take control of my day take control
of my life and start to live with
intention everything starts to shift
the most important part of my morning
routine is intention
every day here's what I do I wake up I
am tired I am I'm groggy I'm I'm like
forget what day it is forget what year
it is forget who I am I wake up I got
stuff in my eyes I got lines on my face
so you know I'm just I'm groggy I don't
wake up excited and like yeah oh my god
let's go we're filming content today you
know I have to remind myself of what I'm
doing and
as I walk to the bathroom
I'll usually put on a song and in the
morning usually I have some oldies
playing because it just makes me happy
so I'll put on some oldie and I'm going
to the bathroom and I find myself just
starting to dance a little bit which is
great because the motion starts to
change things if you put on songs that
make you happy that make you moving it's
going to start to shift your entire day
and music is the fastest way to change
your state and then as I'm going to the
bathroom it might be too much detail
I'll then look at my calendar
I'll look at my calendar
and I'll say how do I want to show up
what's my intention for today
what is my intention for today for how I
want to show up for whatever's in my
calendar today
and today is a Tuesday Tuesdays are when
I make videos I don't know when this is
going to be released but
what's my intention this morning I look
at my calendar I see I've got a bunch of
YouTube videos that I'm going to make
today I'm going to go with Nina and
she's going to run some errands and I'm
going to film from the car
and I want to make content that matters
I want to make something that matters
today I want to I want to make something
that's going to inspire somebody today I
want to make a video that touches
somebody's life today I want to make
potentially the best video I've ever
made today
I want to speak some truth into the
camera I want to touch somebody's soul
in the content that I'm making that's my
goal for today
you think that changes how you show up
right it's like as opposed to just oh
I'm gonna make some videos today okay
cool cool let's go do that
that process doesn't have to take an
hour in the morning
right that process is while I'm going to
the bathroom right it takes takes a
minute
not very long
but it shifts everything
because it changes
how you show up for the entire day I've
also got on my on the background of my
cell phone the background says remember
your intention
as a trigger so anytime I load my phone
I can see that between videos and I
press stop and I'm loading the next one
I see the background of my phone again
remember your intention like yeah what
was my intention this morning because
even if you set it up in the morning it
doesn't mean the whole day is going to
be amazing something's going to throw
you off
you come back to your intention what was
my intention today
and it works for being
your business goals invoice to
accomplishing your business goals it
works for your personal goals on
Saturdays is my fun day and I'll usually
plan something to do with my wife Nina
and maybe it's a hiking trip maybe it's
a we're gonna go out and try out a new
restaurant like it's fun it's not it's
not chores it's not tasks it's not
business it's just something for us to
do so the intentions showing up is
different what's my intention today well
my attention is to be the best husband I
can be what does that mean like not just
words but you're trying to feel it what
does that mean I want to have a great
day with Nina I want to make her smile
today I want to make her laugh today I
want to be present today I want to not
be frustrated by some little thing that
happens I don't want to be sucked into
anything on the work side I don't want
to be daydreaming about business I want
to be thinking about
my life with Nina I want to be
daydreaming about where we're going to
go together as a couple right and the
words will change
but even now that just saying that puts
me into a different mindset I got to
bring it back I want to make killer
videos for you guys
just don't have intention
you know we know we want more you know
you want more you know you want more to
life you know you want to accomplish
more you know you want to be more you
know you want to serve more
and that's a great feeling but we don't
hold on to it long enough to actually do
something with
and we'll usually think of that I want
to do more I know I'm capable of more
and use it to beat ourselves up to say
well look I did I didn't do it I should
have done it last week I should have
started last year I was too afraid to do
it we just beat ourselves up and blame
ourselves for not doing more as opposed
to using that intentionality to then
create a better life for ourselves today
and it starts with today it starts with
today like right now the rest of the day
can be different if you chose to with
intention show up
so how do we do it how do we how to do
how do we do it today how do we do it
ongoing because if you woke up with
intention for the next year
hold a cat is your life look different
step number one
is create the environment of
intentionality and why that matters is
because it allows it to happen on on
Auto on repeat automatically without you
having to think about it because as soon
as you move it to conscious does that
does that step does that barrier does
that block where when it's unconscious
and automatic you're much more likely to
do it so
uh the environment right so my office if
you see my office I got the pictures on
the wall they all mean something to me I
walk past in the morning I walk past my
mannequin uh of of I have a mannequin in
my office or on the way to the office of
of me wearing the hoodie because
superheroes have mannequins of people
wearing their outfits and it it it fires
me up it gets me going I have the music
right put music for how you want to feel
not for how you currently are feeling if
I put music for how I currently was
feeling in the morning and I'm just
tired and just waking up it'd probably
be some slow meditative calm birds
chirping
um waterfall kind of stuff which which
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
not how I if I ask myself how do I want
to start my day it's not with birds
chirping and waterfalls it's with
something that gets me moving because
what I'm missing the most is fun I'm not
feeling fun and energetic in the morning
and so I need that but when I put on the
lion sleeps tonight or when I put on
runarounds or I put on uh
respect you know Aretha Franklin when I
put on you know any of these oldies
I just start moving I start dancing
start singing at the top of my lungs and
that gets me going in the morning right
so the more you can have these habits
and these triggers in the morning to get
you set up
so that when you're looking at the
intention of the day
you're already in the right frame of
mind okay because if you don't have the
right mindset going in no matter what
your intention becomes it's really hard
to get it actually firing right because
you can tell yourself I want to have a
great day but if all you're thinking
about is how slow everything is and how
crappy your life is how you're not
further ahead and and how tired you are
you could say the words but it won't
land as strongly so the the environment
really matters step two is you have to
look at your calendar and see what's
ahead and come into it with intention
how do you want to show up for all the
things that are in your life today
what's on your calendar and schedule
things in right like create a calendar
that maps to your ambition your calendar
should be a macro reflection
of your intention your calendar is an
intentional life
what's in your calendar should be a
reflection of what you want out of your
life
so look at your calendar this is a great
weekly exercise to do look at your
calendar
and then see what in your life what in
what in those spots actually will let
you live the life that you want so you
say you want to be a YouTuber you say
you want to be an entrepreneur say you
want to be a great husband or wife you
say you want great show me in your
calendar where you have dedicated time
to make that intention happen because if
it's just a hope and it's never
scheduled in guess what it never happens
I'm filming content today on a Tuesday
because it's in my calendar because
that's part of an intentional life for
me where if I waited to get inspired to
do something I would make not a lot of
content
right
most of your goals are not in your
calendar and so they never get done
there's a tweetable most your goals are
not in your calendar so it never gets
done
so intentional life is putting things in
your calendar
an intentional day is in reminding
yourself in the morning of what you want
to do is how you show up so when I'm
showing up to make videos I already
explained the process that I go through
but then at night when I'm going to have
time with Nina it's different right the
the I'm not thinking about YouTube
videos anymore I'm thinking about my
time with Nina so an intentional life in
your calendar and in the morning an
intentional day just look at your
calendar and say here's what I need to
do today here's how I need to show up
because again if you plan your week on a
Sunday and planned it all out looks
great
you're going to wake up on a Wednesday
and then forget why you set that as your
goal
that show up with the same
intentionality anymore so the morning
reset for intentionality matters and
then step three is triggers so Step One
is having the environment and the
routine step two is planning out
intentionality in your life which is
your calendar and on a daily basis when
you wake up and then step three is the
triggers to bring you back when you need
to so my biggest Triggers on my cell
phone my biggest trigger is
remember your intention
so that anytime I check my phone I see
that as a reminder to myself of the
person that I said I was going to be
today
the other thing that really helped make
it a big shift in my day-to-day life is
I schedule things in 25 minute
increments so I'm doing interviews I'm
doing calls I'm doing uh whatever's in
my calendar is in 25 or 55 minute
increments before I go to the next thing
I have a five minute buffer before going
into the next thing so if I'm doing
interviews Thursday is my interview day
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom 25 minutes back to back to back to
back to back to back the occasional 55
minutes before the next thing and I
would do it initially just as a buffer
for timing
so in case something went over in case I
had to figure out some tech gear or
because I had to go to the washroom or
whatever I had a five minute break in
between as a buffer
but
the happy accident that came as a result
of it is I use it as a little
intentionality break for the next thing
so yesterday when I'm mentoring my team
if I'm talking to
Jeremy for 55 minutes and then I have
Alex coming up next that five minute
break in the morning it's going to be
how do I want to show up for my team
it's mentoring day I want to show up I
want to be present I want to guide them
I want to help them grow and learn and
be inspired I want to be the best leader
I can be I want them to come away from
today inspired motivated ready for
action fill them with courage and belief
right that's the morning
that sets the tone for the whole day
but in the break between Jeremy and Alex
that five minutes
I'll use a minute or two of it to set
the intention for the next one I just
came from Jeremy I'm going to Alex I
don't want to show up for Alex and I may
just be repeating the same thing that I
came up with this morning or there might
be some Nuance that would be something
different there might be something
unique about Alex that I want to remind
myself of before going into that call
with him
so the daily
reminders of the intention the daily
triggers
one is a cell phone background remember
your intention
and two is having the break the five
minute break between switching tasks to
set myself up for the next task I
remember why I'm doing that specific one
the intention matters
you know again we wake up and
it's so easy to fall into somebody
else's plan for us it's so easy to look
at our text or look at our emails or
look at social media and feel like we're
already behind and we already owe so
many other people in our lives our time
and we don't control our day
and you have to put up
some walls
around where you're spending your time
and you have to start your day with
intentionality to say this is the life
that I want
and I'm doing the activities that move
me towards my goals
and the more that I'm intentional the
more that I am present
the more I will actually start to
accomplish those things
you have so much greatness in you you
have so much heart and so much care and
so much soul and so much of a desire to
do good and serve and help
and yet for some reason at the end of
the week it just didn't happen this week
again and it didn't happen again this
week again
the difference is creating an
intentional life for yourself and then
reminding yourself daily and throughout
the day
of what that intention is
you don't need any more money or any
more support or anything else beyond
what you already have you have
everything you need to win
the only difference between now and
where you could be in a year
is how much are you going to show up
with intentionality every day to move
closer to your goals where does smarts
or where does hard work play a factor in
whether it's building a business being
successful online as an influencer or
whatever it may be
uh I think
intellectual ability has very little to
do with success as an entrepreneur uh I
think if you're seeing working smart
versus working hard that might be
something a little bit different but
there's I mean if being having a high IQ
was the thing that made the difference
then every University Professor would be
super rich
and and they're not and most of them
suck at being entrepreneurs
and so IQ I I think IQ Maps very poorly
actually to be to entrepreneurship when
I was in the VC business we were raising
half a million to 50 million for
companies
um
if somebody gave us their business plan
and you flip to the the team part of it
and they had a PhD on their name
that would count as a strike against
them like ooh they're PhD like no Street
smarts that's not enough statement yeah
that's it's a strike against them it's
against them where in it in the typical
world where you're where you're hiring
people like oh I got phds on my team we
think they're super smart but in the
entrepreneur world and I didn't set this
rule I was 22 years old I was just kind
of following the model that's what VCS
were saying right these guys who are in
their 60s or 70s and built giant
companies and invested in tons of
companies
um yeah he had a PhD it was a strike
against you so there's very little uh if
there is a correlation there might be a
negative one for phds or super smart
people becoming successful entrepreneurs
uh working hard is a prerequisite for
anything in life that you want to get
um working hard is your ticket into the
game
it doesn't guarantee you're going to get
a home run it doesn't guarantee you're
going to win but you don't win without
working hard period
um there's lots of people who work hard
and never win there's lots of people who
you know
I think of think of people in my family
who who have jobs who work crazy hard at
their jobs and
don't get you know paid super super well
for it so you can work really hard and
never
go off and achieve your goals but just
working smart isn't enough
um I think what smart people do is often
find really smart reasons why they can't
win
like I can't win because of this your
purpose comes from your pain the thing
that you struggle the most with as a
human being is what you want to help
other people through for the rest of
your life something terrible happened to
you you know at some point in our lives
something terrible happened to me
happened to you nobody gets through this
life trauma free something terrible
happened to you and that terrible thing
will Define you in one of two ways
either that was negative and in that
story haunts you and holds you back and
and fills you with all these limited
beliefs or
you recognize that that thing that
happened to you is The Ultimate Gift in
that your purpose now becomes to help
other people not struggle the same way
that you did when you can transform that
giant pain that you had emotional pain
when you felt the most worthless as a
human being into something powerful and
positive because it's now not just about
you anymore it's about serving and
helping others who are like you
that's when everything changes my
purpose is to help entrepreneurs believe
in themselves more because the the worst
day of my life the worst moments in my
life for when I was in my first business
and I quit on my business partner and I
I had no belief I
I was down on myself I felt worthless I
felt I was working every day and just
nothing was working out and what do I do
what do I do and I I quit on my business
partner I quit because it was just too
much too much work too much stress too
much negative thoughts too much just
lack of self-worth not enough belief
and I woke up the next day and I and I
still I went back to work because I did
not want to live with the regret and I
actually had a voice of Oprah in my head
telling me just find a different way to
stand
you know if it's not working out it's
okay don't quit just find a different
way to stand and I eventually made it
through
we we built the company sold it had
other successes but
the thing that fills me up forever is
helping other entrepreneurs who are
trying to believe in themselves because
that's back to who I was
and I still make the content for 19 year
old Evan because there are millions of
people out there right now who currently
are 19 year old Evan
and so
one of the most helpful things you can
do
is try to figure out a couple things one
what was that most painful moment like
how do we turn this into
practical a lot of entrepreneurs a lot
of you watching this channel you are
positive you are energetic you are
enthusiastic you are pouring into other
people you're probably the most
optimistic person most dream filled
person in your circle and that's amazing
and that's a gift and you should keep
doing that and
you still have lots of moments where you
don't believe in yourself when you don't
have the courage that you need you don't
have the boldness that you need and and
we don't like looking backwards you
don't like look into the painful moments
the entrepreneurs ambitious positive
people it's like I don't want to think
about all the negative things that
happen to me I want to go off and build
this thing I want to say stocking
negativity is that you can you relate
but it's important to think about that
most painful moment not to sit there and
live there and say oh woe is me but to
recognize
that there are millions of people right
now who currently are still struggling
with that thing that thing that you have
overcome even if you're not done growing
learning and proven yet that thing that
you struggled with that you're coming
through many many many many many
millions of people right now today are
struggling with that thing
and they need you they need your hope
they need your voice they need your
message you need your inspiration you
can reach those people in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't that Oprah Winfrey
can't that other people can't because
you experienced it
and I and Oprah have it
so step number one is to think about
what is that most painful moment
that you struggled through
that you wouldn't wish on anybody else
step number two then becomes well how
did you get out of it again you're not
done climbing but you're way better off
than you used to be it's funny how we
we criticize ourselves for not being
further ahead like I should be up here
her followed that idea I'd be over here
by now all these other people are doing
all these amazing things and I'm still
feeling like I'm stuck okay
but
also look at how far you've come
right you know you want to keep climbing
growing swimming Etc but you've come a
long way compared to who you used to be
and every now and then we need to pause
for flat Pat ourselves on the shoulders
say you know what I'm I'm way further
ahead Than I Used to Be
do you from five years ago or ten years
ago we look at the you today and say
holy cow I can't believe you've done
that
right Evan from 10 years ago who had I
don't know a thousand subscribers on his
YouTube channel would look to Evan now
and say oh my gosh that's crazy I can't
believe you did that even though right
now I'm thinking I gotta do more I got
to be better I gotta work harder gotta
gotta go faster gotta come with new
ideas I'm not pushing enough right if
you look back man there's been some
tremendous growth you've grown a lot
and so how did you how did you get out
of the hole that you were in how did you
stop struggling as much you probably
tried a million different things but
there's one or two or three things that
worked that's teachable
that's teachable to other people the
thing that saved me was modeling success
I looked at Bill Gates's story and I
modeled that for myself and my software
company then started to have success so
what have I taught for the past 20 plus
years now is how can other people model
success so how did you get out of the
hole that you were in
and then how can you then teach that to
other people
because they're struggling because all
of the tests and tries and attempts and
failures that you went through to find
the one two three things that worked you
can Now shortcut somebody else's path
this is what I think it means to max out
your Humanity this is what I what I
think it means to live in what Jonathan
Fields calls maximum sustainable
generosity it's like how can you keep
giving in a sustainable way
that fills you up because you don't want
to just do things for you humans are
built to serve it's wired inside you you
want to feel like you matter like today
matters like the work you're gonna do
today is going to be meaningful to
somebody
and the people you love help the most
are the ones who are currently
struggling with the thing that you
struggled with
so figure out what that thing is that
most painful moment in your life that
you never want to go back to
and then how did you get out of the hole
now that is teachable
and then set number three is having a
courage to share your story
I get it it's scary it's difficult it's
hard to put yourself out there to share
what you went through the struggles you
may be afraid of how you're going to be
judged or seen you know today you were
just a normal person and now tomorrow
you're going to put this out there now
now maybe you're you're scarred or
you're tarnished
but it's important because
by you staying silent it perpetuates the
Silence by you being afraid to share
your story everybody else who's
struggling with the same thing that
you're struggling with they feel afraid
too they feel like they don't belong
they feel like they're weird and not
accepted and not normal
by you putting out your story and what
you went through and are still going
through
it gives the permission to other people
to feel like they have somewhere that
they belong
that they are normal that they're going
to be okay too that they're not alone
so you share in your story I used to
really struggle with thinking well only
egotistical Maniacs share their story
and talk about themselves right it's
about serving well hold on
by you sharing your story is actually
serving you're not sharing your story
just to have the spotlight on you just
to say how amazing you are you're
sharing your story because you're hoping
that other people can see themselves in
you because your purpose comes from your
pain you're trying to reach the people
who currently are who you used to be
and in looking at you and hearing you
what you've come through and where you
are now that will serve as inspiration
for them to keep going
or for them to even get started or for
them to not take their life today
because they saw your video or they read
your book or they saw the post you put
on social media
sharing your story is not about you
sharing your stories about impacting
others and they can see themselves in
you where they can't see themselves in
Evan Carmichael or Oprah Winfrey or
insert you know whatever expert Guru or
entrepreneur
you have to figure out what that most
painful moment in your life was you have
to understand how you got out of the
hole because it's teachable and then you
have to share your story
and put the message out there
because your story will change
somebody's life ultimately your purpose
comes from your pain
you want to serve you want to help you
want to feel like today matters you want
to feel like when you show up to do the
thing that you're going to do today it's
going to have an impact maybe not on
millions of people's lives but on at
least one person's life if you felt like
today you are going to touch in a deeply
meaningful profound way at least one
person's life
you're going to show up totally
differently than if you felt like today
doesn't matter that nobody cares
and just forget about the day
I love you I want to see you win
let's make it happen you have a single
most important core value and when you
figure it out your entire life changes
if you feel like you're being pulled in
a million different directions
you're walking on quicksand everybody
wants something from you you're hot and
cold you want to do something one day
and you don't the other day you have a
hard time saying no to people and to
Opportunities and you're just being
pulled in a thousand directions does
that sound familiar does it sound like
you
if that's you
you don't know what you stand for
because when you know what you stand for
all decisions become easier
I wrote two books on this your one word
and then built the serve and at the core
both of them is figuring out what what
do you stand for what is your single
most important core value and when you
can name it when you can label it when
you can get to the root of it what it
does is give you Clarity for the rest of
your life
mine is belief my one word is belief
I want to believe in myself more and I
want to spread belief to the world to
the people around me it's why I make all
these videos
I make them for myself because I need to
learn and I want to be around the best I
want to be around people who inspire me
to believe more in myself and I try to
spread that to the world
it becomes a filter through which I see
the world it becomes the filter through
which my best self operates
whenever I don't know what to do
whenever I'm given an opportunity
whenever I might be pulled in a thousand
different directions
what do I run that through as well
believe
what would the believe version of Evan
do what do you do
and then that just makes it easier
boom decision made
easier
if you look at my YouTube Channel people
say well you do all these top 10 rules
and you do all these inspiring videos
it's great why not do top 10 of the
stupidest things this person said
or top 10 reasons why not to follow this
person
if I did that if I if I went negative on
Kanye West or Donald Trump or whoever
those videos would actually do better
you know this is where it gets really
tough this is where it really comes down
to what you stand for and how much do
you stand for because when you can get
to the core of who you are that becomes
a lot easier because
making those videos if I was to slam
people
would do better people would much rather
watch negative videos than positive
people would much rather laugh at
somebody else than educate themselves
it's just just how we always rather
watch
big brother and watch reality TV shows
and people tearing each other apart you
can't look away from a car accident or
fight on the street we have this thing
inside us where we like seeing other
people
not doing well because that's how we
feel better about ourselves when you see
somebody else struggling to see someone
else's terrible life on TV makes you
feel better about yourself so we have
this we have this insecurity inside all
of us
and so those videos would do better our
top 10 stupidest things Kanye West has
said would would get more views would
make me more money would lead to more
subscribers would lead to all the
metrics that
that you would probably look at right
you know if I look at what are my goals
I want more subscribers more views more
comments more Revenue it would help all
of that
but it's anti-belief
I don't want I feel gross I don't want
to put that content up I don't want to
put up content slamming people it's not
who I am it's not what makes me come
alive
and this is where you could do it for a
short amount of time and you're going to
start to burn out because you start to
hate your life because you're doing work
that is just against who you want to be
you look at Dave Hollis he's got his one
word of Captain great so what does a
captain do
Captain goes through choppy Waters
Captain is built for the rough Seas
so if he's ever stuck thinking about
should I do this or not well what would
a captain do
and then boom answer
so figuring out your one word figuring
out that most important core value what
it does is give you a roadmap
for the rest of your life and it it
never gets old I will never stop
believing
in myself and others and wanting to
continue to inspire Dave Hollis will
never stop wanting to be the captain
and you need to figure out what yours is
because that gives you direction again
for the rest of your life
so how do we do it how do what are some
of the tactics what are some of the
tricks that you can use because I think
this is one of the most important
exercises you can ever do in your life
understanding what you stand for as a
human
it's not it's not taught you know in
schools it's not taught in textbooks
most of the people who've taught you in
schools they're not happy with the
direction of their life either right
like as you start to get older when
you're when you're a kid and you look at
your parents and adults you feel like
they got it all figured out they have
the answers and then you realize they
have no idea what they're doing like
they're barely hanging on themselves
the teachers who taught you about you
know life in in school they're not happy
with their own life
they haven't figured this out either
but I think it's one of the most
important things that we can learn so
again I have two books on it you're one
word built to serve you want to go
deeper those are great resources but you
start with what are some of the things
that make you come alive
you know who was your favorite teacher
growing up
what movies did you love growing up what
did you love about how your parents
raised you even if you hate your parents
was there anything that you can pull out
that you loved
and what you're doing is looking at what
are some of the things that tie these
things together
so if you had the right this is the
exercise I do with people
okay tell me your favorite movie and
three words to describe it
tell me who your favorite teacher was
and three words to describe them think
about your favorite teacher growing up
favorite coach your favorite mentor
it's not because they taught you grade 8
science
right it wasn't that material they
taught you they made you feel better as
a human they taught you how to be a
better person why what did they do
I was talking to a woman yesterday
coaching her through this process we did
an Instagram live together she's part of
my movement makers program in just past
a year being in the program so we did a
live together and she wanted to go
through this exercise how do I find my
one word
and her favorite teacher growing up
wasn't a teacher but was her coach she
was a track coach and one of the things
that she loved about the track coach was
he would get in and do it with her
so whenever she was tired whenever she
wanted to quit whenever she didn't feel
good enough he wouldn't just give her
words but he would do it with her he'd
say okay
I'll do the last one with you race me
he would run alongside her
so as you think about it what what was
your favorite teacher growing up who was
it and and why write down
some descriptive keywords and what
you'll find is if you do that with who
your favorite mentors are who your
favorite teachers are what your favorite
books or videos are look at my Channel
all the people we profiled and who were
the people that you resonate with the
most if you love me what are three words
of whatever Carmichael that you love you
love Dave paulus what are three words
that describe Dave Hollis you know all
the good things that that you love that
make you feel alive and bold and
confident and serving and wanting to
help all those things are connected
but they don't feel connected this is
the problem this is the the connective
tissue work that you have to do this is
where
we never learn these things the things
that you love are not just random
occurrences they're connected
when you write them down the descriptive
keywords you'll see a trend that happens
between them
so for me it's belief my favorite movie
is Seabiscuit it's about a horse that's
too small and a jockey that's too big
and a team owner that's going bankrupt
and somehow they come together find each
other and win all of these races and
it's based off a true story and they go
and beat the the well-funded you know
the team that has the perfect jockey and
the giant horse and the tons of money
and they go and they beat those guys
right so if I were to write down you
know the three words believe is on there
I might say Underdog I might say
inspiring I might say believe I would
say believe you know and then if I think
about my favorite teacher growing up
Madame Farr taught me French but I don't
even use my French like French isn't
even that valuable for the work that I
do why do I love Madame Farr well
because she believed in me because she
would meet with me once a week when I
was in my
graduating year
and
she just asked me about my life how I
was doing in school I was introverted I
was shy
you know it was harder for me to make
friends and feel like I fit in and
belonged and so for her I might put
belong I would definitely put the leave
and I might put something else maybe
care or compassion
in those meetings with her once a week
turned me from a BNC student into a
straight A student when I didn't think
that that was possible for for me to do
it because I never really gotten A's my
entire School career so
we start to look at the similarities
right that I'm far
believe you know compassion Etc
Seabiscuit Underdog believe right
there's different keywords that will
show up but what's a consistent one
believe
Ah that's interesting
it's interesting this keeps coming up
what would happen if I built my whole
life around belief
what would happen if I built my business
around belief what would happen if I
created a schedule
and a calendar and habits and routines
that made me feel more belief what would
happen if I could spread that belief to
others what would happen if I brought on
team members who love believe and helped
spread believe with their skills and
talents what would happen if I had my
significant other
believe in me right what would happen
What would how much has life changed
everything Everything Changes because
now I'm designing a life
with intent
purpose
and with design
as opposed to randomly having things
experienced for me to me because
everybody's got an agenda for your time
everybody wants you to do certain things
and that's when you feel lost and being
pulled in a million different directions
you have to figure out what you stand
for I think it's the most important
thing you can do as a human what do you
stand for what's your single most
important core value
some people get it right away from the
exercises some people take some time and
you you sit on it and it becomes more
and more right or more and more wrong
but when you find it
and you get that Compass you get that
road map it's with you for the rest of
your life it makes every decision easier
it makes you live a lot more in
alignment and makes you feel like what
you're doing is important that it
matters it gives you the confidence and
the Courage the thing that you're afraid
to do to step outside your comfort zone
to build the business and the life that
you want
and ultimately to make you happy
to make you happy
and then you can spread that happiness
to others will help them believe in
themselves too I would look at two kinds
of people to model from one the people
who've already made it in your industry
so if you're in software look at people
who are doing software like if you're
trying to be successful on YouTube
Follow other YouTubers and doesn't mean
you copy copy and paste
your business
people look to are just people who you
look up to you know if you want to be a
YouTuber but you love Steve Jobs you
know there's something you can learn
from him and because you love him so
much he's your favorite entrepreneur
then you'll be able to take lessons and
apply that to your business and so
whoever it is that you look up to you
can learn from them and find a tweet to
bring that to your industry it one gives
you specific ideas so you know Bill
Gates partnership's great I'm going to
apply that and two also gives you at
least help for me it helped gave me a
lot of motivation because a lot of these
guys if you look at the heroes you look
up to Chances Are they started from less
than what you already have right now and
so seeing them do it just gave me
confidence that like why can't I do it I
can do it too and most people's
environments aren't massively supportive
most people don't have parents telling
them you're going to be a great
entrepreneur keep going and friends like
wow you're so good right like most
people I say their family their friends
like what what are you doing are you
making money is this isn't gonna work
and so it can be hard to be the the lone
person betting on this dream and
everybody else around you you know
doesn't get it and so changing your
circle it's why you know these people
are behind me on my wall here in my
office you want to have an environment
of success and that is motivating as
well as a tangible kind of how to's to
grow your business treat yourself like
you matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about think about how
you talk to other people you know think
about if you're watching this video if
you're a fan of this channel you are
probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even Tech even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror and you're just telling yourself
all the reasons why you can't do
something that voice inside your own
head sucks right telling yourself that
you can't make it to someone like you is
never going to do it we don't treat
ourselves with the same love of
compassion empathy that we have
for other people you wouldn't talk to
your worst enemy the way that you talk
to yourself
and that's a big problem I think that
needs to shift that needs to change
because as long as you keep
talking to yourself
like you're a piece of garbage
then you're never going to accomplish
anything great
we have to start to shift it
I had a whole bunch of issues in how I
talk to myself
I used to say well I'm I'm too shy I'm
too introvert I'm nobody's going to want
to hear my story my message doesn't
matter who am I to go off and do this I
have to have a huge ego even I'm sitting
here filming in a parking lot like I
would I would never do this only only
people with giant egos and
uh loud mouths would ever do that right
I'm still working to unwind all of that
but the more you can catch it
and the more you can shift it it allows
you to go off and do great things not
just for yourself but for other people
because if you fast forward
if the way you've been talking to
yourself for the past couple of years
continues to be the way that you talk to
yourself for the rest of your life
nothing changes
so how do we shift how do we get to a
point where hey we're actually saying
better things about ourselves number one
is you have to catch the voice you know
what is the negative voice what are you
saying to yourself because a lot of it
are just
it's not intentional
you know it's these automatic thoughts
it's a subconscious thoughts you come up
with an idea of what you can do and
immediately you shut yourself down
without even noticing it just it's a
default nature instantly boom no I can't
do that no you suck you can't do that
so what are the negative thoughts that
are coming up in your mind and just
trying to catch it
number two is whatever you want to have
more of you need to create that in your
life you need to create the habits and
routines to have more of it in your life
so for me I want more belief right and I
go through this whole process of how to
figure out your most important core
value or your one word you can pick up
your one word or build the serve it'll
walk you through it
what do you need more of in your life I
need more belief and as much as I'm
trying to spread that to the world with
the videos and everything I make I also
need more of it myself I need more
belief for myself and so what helps me
believe in myself well I try to design a
life in an environment to help bring
that out more so
everything from the outfit that I wear
you know I tell myself I'm a superhero
going to work this is my believe uniform
just like Batman puts on his costume
from what my office looks like and the
pictures on my wall I've got my parents
on my wall and
looking at them reminds me of the
message that my mom would always give me
that I'm Advocate Shirley Carmichael I
could do anything and believe that I can
the videos that I make the the main
channel the top 10 Channel this Channel
all the content that I make is designed
to help me believe in myself more
that's what helps me come alive
um service you know thinking about
how what I'm gonna do will have an
impact on somebody else besides me
helps me have the courage to go off and
Chase down the goals that I have for
myself so what is it that makes you come
alive what do you need more of it in
your life because you're probably not
getting enough of it
right the thing that you need more in
your life you're not you're not getting
enough of it right now that's why that
negative voice is so powerful and
default
so think about the people who you're
hanging around and the media you're
consuming all of it you're not getting
enough of the thing that you need so how
do you get more of that thing and
engineering design it so that it's part
of your daily calendar that's not
randomly happening in your life but it's
with intent
must happen every day
so number one is catching that horse
what is that voice
number two is designing that environment
and the habits and the routines for
yourself so that you're around it
constantly you're changing our
environment to be around the thing that
you know that you want to be
and then number three is
Empower people to pull you out of the
Matrix you know Empower people to call
you out Empower people to give you
feedback
some of my favorite ways to do it
whenever I'm going to an event or
whatever I'm talking to somebody I
respect and I need some help input
guidance feedback I'll say tell me why I
suck remember I suck at this thing why
do I suck at this like how do I get
better
and when I do that it's because they
give me their honest feedback you know
when when you just ask for feedback
people will be afraid of hurting your
feelings and you won't get the full info
so I say tell me why I suck and they say
well you don't suck but
here's what you need to fix
I empower the people around me that if I
say scary difficult or hard
then I have to go up and do the thing
just because I said scary difficult to
heart I don't want to be the person who
plays small so my son particularly loves
this one right it's like that you did it
you said scary oh shoot okay now I have
to go off and do it what are your
trigger words what are the things that
make you stay small and then empower the
people around you to call you out on it
so that
when you don't catch it because you
won't catch it most of the time you
won't catch it but when you can't catch
it and somebody else can
not being defensive and not uh
putting our guard up and realizing that
hey this behavior is keeping me stuck
empowering the people around you to give
you the feedback to pull you out of the
Matrix so you can start turning what
subconscious to conscious
if you feel like
you're a little bit stuck
you know you want to do more and you're
capable of more and you want to serve
more and help more
and you know that you've got this voice
inside you that's keeping you there and
you're struggling with how do I get it
from subconscious and automatic negative
to subconscious and automatic positive
everything starts to change
you have to treat yourself like you
matter
just imagine that you were actually your
own best friend
just imagine that you came to you with
the problems that you're facing what
would you tell yourself
it's probably going to be something
loving something encouraging something
powerful something positive not the
words that you're actually using to talk
to yourself
this doesn't change in a day you know it
doesn't change in an instant it's a
process
but if every day
by day you can slowly start to believe
in yourself more Empower yourself more
talk to yourself in a better way
you're going to create
a much better life for yourself and then
you can pay it forward and help others
because no matter what words you say no
matter how much you tell people to be
positive again you're here watching this
you are the most positive person in your
in your family you're pouring into other
people no matter how much words you use
what they'll be inspired by most is your
action
no matter how much you say hey love
yourself make this happen I believe in
you if they see you not believing in
yourself not taking the action you need
to take they'll never be inspired to do
it themselves either
they'll be most inspired by the actions
that you take when you're afraid and you
doubt yourself to it's time to make a
change let's make that change today just
start just start start like that idea
start go stop finding reasons why you
can't win stop finding all the
roadblocks that are in your way and just
get started I lost a 40 million dollar
deal when I was
because I had to have the perfect plan
and it was you know again back to fear
too afraid to launch something without
the perfect plan and I lost I lost a 40
million dollar deal because of it so
just start that thing you think you want
to do great find a way to get started on
it you want to you want to make a
YouTube channel pull out your phone and
go make your first video today
um just start on your ideas finding your
purpose is easy finding your purpose
finding your passion finding what you're
meant to do is easy and I will beat this
drum until everybody figures it out
because it's one of the most common
questions that I keep getting asked
we're not taught this in school the
people that we're learning from are not
people who are living their purpose
either your purpose it comes from your
pain that's a simple answer whatever you
struggled with whatever you felt the
lowest as a human whenever you felt the
most worthless the most like you didn't
belong that moment that's your purpose
to help other people who are currently
going through that for optimistic happy
ambitious people we usually don't like
looking backwards into the pain if
you're the kind of person watching these
videos you're probably the kind of
person who's born into others who's
loving others who's optimistic who's
trying to not think about the rain
that's happening today right not
focusing on the rain but focusing on the
opportunities and the Sunshine to come
right that's probably you
okay so the point is not to sit in the
previous pane the point is to use that
as Leverage
for yourself to jump into the next level
of life for you a more meaningful a more
purposeful a more intentional life
whatever you struggled with the most
there are millions of people right now
who are struggling with the same thing
they're struggling with the exact same
thing as you did
and they need your help they need your
guidance you need your wisdom they need
your story they need your hope they need
your light they need your love they need
your energy they need you they need you
to show up
that's your purpose and that will never
get old that will never get old that
will never get old every time you see
somebody
who is a younger version of you
and you can have a conversation with
them
and you can see the Hope light up in
their eyes that now they feel like
something is possible because they met
you
that's a feeling that will never get old
I'll be you know 200 years old sitting
in an old age home
still trying to help people believe
themselves more because that's what I
struggled with the most I am still
making content I am still speaking and
writing books and creating videos and
doing podcasts and shows and everything
I do is because I'm trying to help 19
year old Evan 1911 who
turned down his dream job to start a
business to make 300 a month to have no
self-belief to feel like I made the
biggest decision the worst decision of
my life
I felt like I made the worst decision in
my life instead of taking that dream job
to do this business it was it was hooray
Euphoria for a couple weeks and then
realized oh my gosh
this is a lot harder than I thought and
I'm not making any money
did I make a big mistake
and all my friends were making tons of
money at those investment banking jobs
that I could have had
and I felt lost and I felt hopeless and
I felt like
I made a big mistake and I was working
like crazy and I was too embarrassed and
too ashamed to to ask people for help
to let people in
and I didn't believe in myself at all
that's who I love helping I love helping
humans you know I want to help humans
believe in themselves but
the the softest spot in my heart is for
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
their thing off the ground because I
remember how hard it was for me to get
my thing off the ground and
I quit there was one day that I actually
quit on my business partner
and thankfully I went back the next day
you know thankfully I didn't I didn't
fully quit all the way because I would
have regret that
and I think a lot of people do you end
up quitting too soon on your dreams
and so that's who I'm trying to help
with all with all my content with all my
work with everything I do with 12 000
plus videos later I'm still doing it
people ask me how do you stay so
consistent how have you made videos
for 12 years and have not burnt out
well because I love what I'm doing
because I feel like it matters I don't I
don't love the idea of just sitting here
in the parking lot of a Costco making a
video but I love the idea that this is
talking to you that hello I'm a part of
your routine I appreciate you thank you
so much
and so you can have that too
you know whatever you struggled with
there are millions of people who are
struggling with that right now
and they don't know who to go to they
won't listen to Evan Carmichael because
I haven't struggled with the thing that
you struggled with
but to listen to you because you've been
through it
the next part becomes well who Am I who
am I to have this mission who am I to
help these people I'm still trying to
figure it out myself do you resonate
with that it's like who am I to be this
person doesn't help people I I still
want to have all the answers myself
and imposter syndrome starts to creep in
right you ever felt that
there's so many better people out there
than you and you're an imposter for even
trying
so the way to combat imposter syndrome
is two ways and
leverage both I've leveraged both and
still leverage both because I still feel
at times that I'm not good enough and
they're better people than me and so
here's the two things that I use
number one you see your growth as a
staircase
your growth is a staircase
and you know you want to climb forever
you don't want to ever stop growing you
don't ever stop learning as soon as you
feel like you've stopped learning and
stop growing you start to really hate
your life
you always want to feel like you're
growing and learning somewhere
so look at your growth as a staircase
and when you're doing imposter syndrome
what you're doing is looking at the
people who are ahead of you on the
staircase and saying oh my gosh look at
that person they're so much further
ahead of me I suck I get why can't I be
like them why can't I be like Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or Tony Robbins or
whoever your heroes are that you look up
to and respect and feel like they're so
far ahead of you
and because you're not where they are
means in your own head you can't do
anything you can't share your message
you're not worthy enough right
well what you need to recognize is
you're still on your your staircase as
well but you're not at Step Zero you're
if if Oprah and Elon Musk are at step 8
000 maybe you're at step 100.
great
but you're not at Step Zero
you've come a long way you like to look
back instead of only looking forward to
see everything that you haven't done yet
look back to see where you've come from
like oh my gosh you know what I'm at
step 100
it's nowhere close to where I want to be
I haven't figured it all out but I've
learned so much more compared to who I
used to be
then understand that
most people
who are struggling with the thing that
you struggled with
they're still at Step Zero
and you're in step 100. you can help
them you can't help them get the 8 000
level but you can help them get to step
100 because that's where you're at
most of the people who are struggling
right now are at Step Zero
and they need a little bit of help and
they need someone to believe in them
enough to help carry them to Step One
and step two and step three
it's your job to give them that hope and
to give them that momentum and you can
and the way I like to think about it is
every time I take another step up on my
journey
you reach back and you help somebody
else out who's behind you
help other people
climb on and rise on their Journey
because learning alone isn't enough we
want to feel like what we do matters we
want to feel like we're having an impact
that's where purpose comes from we all
want to wake up every day and feel like
the work that we do is going to matter
to somebody you want to feel like today
is important
I want to feel like today is important
what I tell myself at least is that
people are going to watch this video and
somebody's going to get inspired enough
to take some kind of action for somebody
watching this video this video will be
the one that actually pushes you over
the edge into action mode
whether that's true or not I don't know
but I hope it's what I tell myself and
that's how I get the meaning behind
doing the work because I'm just sitting
in my car in a Costco parking lot with
my dog here
making a video talking to my phone
but we want to feel like what we do
matters
so every time you take a step up on that
staircase it's great to have people who
are ahead of us that we learn from and
look up to but every time we take a step
up we pull somebody else up with us
and most people who are struggling
are still way way way behind you
so you don't have to have all the
answers
but you have enough answers to help the
people who are at the start
so that's one if you're struggle with
imposter syndrome you know we found our
purpose it's to help people who are
currently who we used to be what we used
to struggle with
we're trying to figure out imposter
syndrome step number one is a staircase
of growth step number two is imagining
you
sitting with yourself from 10 years ago
think about who you used to be 10 years
ago five years ago like you've grown a
lot if you're watching this channel
you're subscribed here you're into
personal development you don't want to
stay stuck you you have grown a lot you
have
if not from my content from other videos
from other books from other podcasts
you've grown a lot like hey high five
congrats it's amazing
so imagine you're going to sit down on a
park bench
with the you from five or ten years ago
and you've got five minutes with that
person you got five minutes with former
you
think you could share something with
them that might Inspire them
you think you could share something with
them that might give them hope or some
momentum a little bit of motivation
think about what message you might share
and when I've done this with live
audiences they'll say things like
it's going to work out
you're going to be okay
believe in yourself
you'll get through this
you're stronger than you think
you know as I as I ask live audiences
these are the things that they say on
the microphone or popped in the chat and
everybody all of these people who
at the beginning couldn't find their
purpose and struggled with imposter
syndrome now all of a sudden have
absolute Clarity and certainty with a
message they would tell the younger self
[Music]
okay great so if you are convinced that
you can help younger you
just recognize that there are millions
of people who are younger you
if you can help the you from five years
ago from 10 years ago that's what most
of the people are struggling with right
now
and that becomes your message
your purpose comes from your pain
you don't need to spend years on a
mountain
figuring it out you don't have to spend
journals upon journals upon journals you
don't need to hire an expensive coach to
help you through this your purpose comes
from your pain
whatever you struggled with is the thing
you want to help other people through
period and it will be with you for the
rest of your life
and when you can spend the time to
figure that out
and then do the exercises to overcome
that imposter syndrome that will come as
your next step
it unlocks everything
it unlocks
gratitude it unlocks purpose it unlocks
happiness it unlocks fulfillment
because what it does is give you this
well of energy
to then go off and do the scary
difficult things
to finally get out of the way of your
mind holding you back telling you that
little voice telling you you can't do
things because it's no longer just about
you it's about helping other people
and every time you can shift it from
being about you to helping others it
gives you that extra little bit of
courage to go off and do the thing
because you built to serve because you
want to help
because you got a big mission inside you
and the only difference between where
you are now and where you will be in a
year
is how much momentum and how much belief
you create in yourself to make that
Vision a reality most people sleep walk
through life because they don't love
what they're doing you wake up and you
don't love what you're doing you feel
like it doesn't matter or you feel like
nobody will care if you show up or you
don't and if if that was your day
if you today felt like you know what it
doesn't matter I show up I don't show up
I make I don't make nobody's gonna
really care if that was not just today
but tomorrow the next day the next day
the next day if that was every day of
your life how sad would your life be
this is why we have so much anxiety and
depression and suicide is because people
feel like they don't matter and we want
to matter to others it's wired into us
we want to feel like we are important we
want to feel like what we're going to do
today is going to create some kind of
meaning and impact on somebody else's
life we are built to serve you want to
help it's not enough to want to do
something just for yourself you want to
feel like you matter to somebody else
today
most people sleepwalk through their
lives
never feeling like they meant anything
to anybody especially in their work
and it's why a lot of people default to
entrepreneurship to try to say well
here's my chance to be to be My Own Boss
use my chance to live my own life here's
my chance to do something that matters
without just being some Cog in a
corporate machine
but unless you connect the work that
you're doing to serving and helping
other people you still won't feel great
when I first started in my business it
was really really hard
both businesses but the business where I
helped Inspire entrepreneurs and I got
asked to speak and I remember just
loving the speaking part and at the time
I was doing a speaking gig a month or so
and just wasn't getting enough feedback
I'd go and it'd be amazing I'd be
certain so nervous and so scared to get
up on stage
but then the end would be so amazing and
to see that you helped somebody you know
how good it feels to help somebody
you know how good it feels to make
somebody smile or laugh or cry or
for them just to say thank you
you know you know you know how good it
feels when somebody says thank you for
what you've done for me today
that is more valuable than whatever
they're paying you for your product or
service right we all want that that's
the good thing to get addicted to so
when I first started speaking and
helping
I I was getting that once a month and
doing a speaking gig but then I wasn't
feeling it throughout the month this is
the hard part of being an entrepreneur
especially at the beginning when you
don't have enough feedback you're not
feeling valuable it takes too long to
get your product to service or service
to Market to see the at the action that
your customers are getting from it
and so I had to remind myself of what I
was doing I had to remind myself I made
a PowerPoint file where I looked at my
comments every day the feedback that I
was getting even though it was for three
weeks ago I still looked at the feedback
again to remind myself of what I was
doing was important
when I started my YouTube Channel I
didn't get any feedback I wasn't getting
any comments right my first video took a
year to get three comments and it was my
mom my older sister and then some random
guy so I wasn't getting a lot of
feedback
but I still would look at my comments
every day just to feel like hey this is
important like if I got one comment a
week I'd be so happy it's like yeah I
see that person I helped that person
I gotta keep going I gotta keep making
got to keep creating
and even to this day it still is among
the most important things that I do
I'm I'm pretty in love with Discord
right now I created my own Discord
server you can join believe Nation it's
Evan carmichael.biz it's free and I'm in
there every morning right now
just helping and it's one of my go-to's
right now for how I start my day start
my day I look at my calendar I set my
intention for the day and then I'll go
to my Discord server and start helping
people
because
having a million views on a video or
however many subscribers or whatever it
does not feel as good as going into
Discord server and helping one person
believing themselves a little bit more
so you have to figure out a way to make
it
not a Sleepwalk every day
to make it feel like you're doing
something that matters that you matter
that today is going to matter that you
show up in a way that matters so let me
break down a couple things that I think
can help number one is the big picture
has to matter
this is why people struggle in jobs
because you feel like nobody cares right
this job doesn't mean anything
the company doesn't care if I'm here or
not even the company's Mission isn't
that important you don't feel connected
to what you're doing every day you have
to feel connected to the mission
if you're an entrepreneur it's a lot
easier but you have to be doing work
that you actually think matters a lot of
entrepreneurs start a company just
trying to make money you're just trying
to pay the bills you're just trying to
make some cash you're just trying to
look at the hot opportunity and if you
can't connect to the reason why you're
doing it the mission you won't win the
number one rule for success is you have
to love the thing that you're doing if
you're doing it just to make money
making money is important it is
important you have to do it it needs to
be in your top five but it can't be
number one what is number one
you have to design your business that
you feel like you're on a mission that
you're here to serve that you're doing
some kind of good that you you may not
be there yet you may not be
accomplishing anything close to it yet
but it's the goal it's the mission that
you're trying to go off and achieve
so number one is you have to feel like
on a big scale on a macro scale that if
it all plays out this is going to really
really really really really matter to
you but to other people as well
two is the micro wins have to be there
you know it's the it's the Big Y and the
little y so the first one is the Big Y
the big why what am I trying to
accomplish the second one is a little
wide little wise the daily little wins
you could be
inspired by your big why
it could be driving you it could be
fulfilling you but
there will be many days with a Big Y is
not enough
there'll be many days where you feel
like you can't do that big why that who
were you to think you could do that
crazy big thing that it's never going to
happen that you're not going to make it
that it's just it's just not worth it
there'll be many days where you feel
like that
especially when you don't see any
tractional momentum happening that's
what the little y's come into place the
little Y is the daily little feeling
like hey I did something to help one
person I may not be able to impact the
world today I may not be having a
life-changing product or service or
launch or video or whatever but I can
help one person today that's why I go to
the Discord every morning that's why I'm
in my comments every day because
my big why is to change the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I'm never going to do
it and there are days where that feels
way too big and too scary I channel that
into this like this video I want this
video to matter I'm sitting here in the
parking lot in my car while Nina's at a
a pet store getting stuff for the dogs
right I'm just talking to my cell phone
but I want this video to matter I want
this video to touch you I want this
video to have some kind of meaningful
impact that maybe this is the day the
way that I say the words the energy that
I show up with maybe maybe just maybe
this is a day that you finally go off
and make some kind of change maybe today
is the day that's my sincere hope
and
I need to still feel like
I'm touching somebody that talking to my
phone is not enough so going to the
Discord server talking to people
encouraging them giving them some love
just saying good morning just helping
people
it's crazy doing DMS in the morning on
my Instagram and spending eight seconds
making a video for somebody and then
seeing the reaction like you don't know
how much this video meant to me that you
would send this it's coming to me at the
right time today I really needed that
encouragement
took me eight seconds to do but it
changed somebody's life right is that
going to help me grow my subscribers or
comments or Revenue no right but it
feels really good
and you need those little y's so what
are the things that
are connected to your big mission
but are really small but it's a it's an
individual that you can help one person
that by you helping one person today
you've got your little why that can give
you the motivation to keep going
how do we stop sleepwalking through life
right Big Y you're on a big mission that
you're trying to accomplish something
huge step two is a little why we feel
like today is going to matter to
somebody to one human even if it doesn't
accomplish our big mission step number
three is to pay it forward
you know how good it feels to get a
comment to get a video to get a
personalized message for somebody to
help you out
Pay It Forward especially to small
creators my ask for you would be if you
if there's somebody that you follow
somebody who you who whose Journey
you're following along with maybe it's
your friend who's posting maybe it's
some total stranger who you've found
some of their content
go give them a little love
go get them a review on iTunes go give
them a comment on their YouTube or
Instagram or wherever you're following
them
it means so much
if it's a giant Channel
or someone's been doing it for a long
time you know I don't see all the
comments that come in don't don't leave
a comment on if you could I mean leave a
comment on the videos but it doesn't
mean as much anymore as it used to right
because we get so many so we're spoiled
so the big the big creators don't worry
about it you can it's always good karma
that's to spread positivity but if you
had to pick
pick for the smaller ones
because just one person saying I see you
just one person saying thank you just
one person saying this message meant
something to me this just one just one
person
having that belief
is the difference quite often between
them quitting and them following through
your single message today to somebody
is going to be the difference I promise
you for somebody if you did that every
day it will for sure be the difference
for quite a number of people between
them quitting and then continuing on
because you took 15 seconds to send a
quick message to them
so Big Y little Y and then pay it
forward especially to the small creators
we gotta get out of the Sleepwalk guys
we we want to feel like we matter we
want to feel like today matters we want
to feel like the work we do matters and
the best way that you can inspire people
you want to help the people around you
you want to help your community you want
to help your family you want to help the
people who might see you you want to
help people the best way to help them is
for you to stop sleepwalking is for you
to start doing things that matter it's
not for you to just
make a inspirational video
it's through your actions that if you
showed up today and decided that you're
going to remember your big why that
you're going to serve with your little
why that you're going to pay it forward
to other people
when you see the impact that that can
have on their life
it makes you reconnect to why you do
what you do
and if you woke up and did the thing
that made you remember why you do what
you do and you felt it not just words
you're telling yourself but you
genuinely felt it
holy cow look out because life starts to
get really really good the voice inside
your head telling you that you can't do
something is not your voice
it was put there
it was planted there
it was fertilized there by the people
around you by your parents by your
teachers by your friends Growing Up by
Society it was put there think about it
when when you
were born when you were young I don't
know what your earliest memories are but
you see kids everything is possible
you're like I'm gonna be an astronaut
and I'm going to be an architect at the
same time and you know my goal growing
up I was going to be a baseball player
play for the Toronto Blue Jays my
hometown team and I was going to be a
police officer in the off season
so be professional baseball player I
love Kelly Gruber growing up third
baseman for the Toronto Blue Jays and in
the off season
gonna be a police officer
because I love police officers like
everything is possible
everything is possible the kids and then
what happens
suddenly we start to get older and we
realize that
things aren't that way and we have to be
safe and we have to be practical and we
have to be smart
and that message gets drilled into us
and it could be your parents it could be
your friends it could be the school
system it could be the media it could be
Society there's lots of it
think about the people who are giving
you the advice
think about the people
that's why it's so valuable think about
the people telling you that you can't do
something
and how many of those people genuinely
love their life
the people telling you you can't do
something how much of them actually love
their life not a lot
they don't
what gives them the authority
to tell you that you can't do it some
people will do it out of fear
it's love but fear right maybe your
mom's telling you you can't do something
but she loves you probably
she's telling you because she wants you
to be happy she's telling you because
she's afraid she's telling you because
if you go off and do something that
doesn't work what's going to happen to
your life she's living from a place of
insecurity right that but it's love
and some people do it because of
jealousy
they try to live their dream they took
their shot and it didn't work out and so
now nobody else around them is allowed
to succeed instead of going and taking a
second shot they spend their time trying
to tear other people down
but either way
they're not happy
they never lived their life they never
chase after their goals they never
pursued their dreams
and now they're telling you that you
can't get married most people are not
happy
look at any
survey any study and or even just think
about it think about the people saying
no in your life are they does this
person actually love their life
probably you know
so why we listen to them
and this is this is a problem because
most people don't love their lives right
and so you're surrounded by it's
everywhere it's it's in everything that
you're picking up and so it takes a
conscious effort to start to shift that
and this is why so many people when they
do learn when they do improve when
you've you've been on a personal
development personal growth Journey when
you learn something you want to go help
the people around you right the first
thing we want to do the first instinct
is to then bring it to the people around
us
because
we want the world to be better
right
so that voice is not yours that voice is
planted the mistake is thinking that
it's yours the mistake is thinking that
that insecure voice inside your head is
actually you talking it's not you
talking
that voice telling you that you suck
that you can't do this as someone like
you will never make it that's not you
that's not your real voice that is your
parents that is your school that is
society that is the media that's not
your voice that's what you've been
conditioned to believe
so how do we how do we start to change
it
um the goal of this video is not to be
you know giant conspiracy theory the
world's against us but it's possible
like how do you change it how do you
start to shift it well
we need to recognize one that that's not
your voice do you believe that that's
your voice because as long as you
believe that that's you you stay small
you stay stuck you stay listen to it
because you're telling yourself that you
can't do it so step one is to recognize
that that is not actually your voice and
if you can do the deeper work to figure
out whose is it
whose voice is that is that your parents
is that your brothers is that your
schools is that the meeting you're
consuming is that like who is it whose
voice is that and why do you still care
about listening to that voice like
that's some deeper work but if you
figure that out it'll allow you to stop
listening to it
step two is
to start to eliminate the things in your
life now that make that voice louder
maybe you're hanging around some people
who you shouldn't be friends with
anymore
you know maybe just because you're
friends with somebody in high school
doesn't mean you should still be their
friend now
you know maybe you've Grown Apart
now it's time to get some new friends
do an audit of the people that you're
following on Instagram and on YouTube
and any social media I mean whatever
you're feeding your brain with do an
audit and think about are these people
which voice are they empowering
there's a great story about two wolves
you know I'm going to paraphrase it but
there's two wolves inside you one who
wants the best for you and one who wants
to grow and learn and improve and serve
and share and be courageous and the
other wolf is is scared and Afraid and
keeping you small and stuck and insecure
and weak
and it goes well who which wolf wins
who's the wolf that ends up
carrying the day
the answer is the one that you feed
so if you feed the wolf all your
insecurities and fears and doubts then
that that wolf is going to win and you
will be
afraid and full of insecurities and
doubts and if you feed the wolf that
makes you feel bold and courageous and
Powerful then you will become that too
so that process we need to recondition
ourselves by changing the environment by
being around the people who are doing
the things that we want to do
so do that audit of the people you
follow on YouTube and Instagram and how
much of your time here's here's the test
is when you walk away from a video when
you walk away from the app that you're
on you feel better about yourself you
feel Bolder more courageous more
powerful if you're watching this video
you know when you watch my channel do
you feel better about yourself or you
feel with more belief ready to take on
the day yes great hey I got more videos
for you stay tuned no I sincerely
apologize
because that is not the goal but but
then if that is happening then then yes
unsubscribe for me and go follow some
other people
you know and same thing for other people
you follow on Instagram how many of
those people
make you feel better do you leave your
phone feeling better about yourself more
courageous bold ready to start today or
do you just waste a whole bunch of time
and feel worse about yourself great
those people unfollow them everybody who
makes you feel that way stop following
them
and replace them because I guarantee you
that if you look for the light you'll
find the light
oh it's a good one you know if you look
for the light you'll find the light
there are people
on every social platform in every part
of the world who are
spreading kindness spreading belief
spreading hope spreading possibility
they exist everywhere
it's not common
it's not the default yet that's why lack
of belief I believe is the world's
number one problem because it's not
default yet but there are people
spreading the light
find them
be around them
hang out with them collect them learn to
collect good people
it'll shift everything
so you've got a real important decision
to make
do you listen to your heart
the the feeling that you want to do more
and serve more and help more and be more
and create more or do you listen to that
voice
that's not your voice
inside your head telling you all the
reasons why
you can't do it
it's a choice
you have to decide which wolf you're
going to feed
both wolves exist inside you the
insecure wolf
and the powerful wolf
and either one could win
it'll dramatically change your life
which one you feed
you just have to decide which one are
you going to feed today that idea that
you have
find a way to get started on it right
now
trust your ideas trust that if you got
this idea it came to you for a reason
it's a great idea you have to do
something about it coming up with ideas
and then writing down
you know in your notebook or email or
whatever your list of ideas you're never
going to attack that list of ideas your
your list of ideas is just going to
build and build and build and build and
build and grow how do you attack it by
doing
so what you need to do is when you get
an idea most people what they'll do is
they'll make it bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger the idea like I'm
going to start I'm going to start a
YouTube channel oh and then from that I
can have big guests come on my show and
then from that I can then build a huge
email list and from that I can run my
own conferences and from that I can do I
need to make this some giant thing but
the bigger it is the more impossible it
is to start
now you need a team now you need
financing now you need all the skills
and training that you don't have you
think well I can't do that instead you
switch and just say what can I do right
now
so whether you want to start a YouTube
channel or make a song or write a book
or create a podcast or whatever whatever
idea you have start by just starting
right now don't worry about the perfect
first step because in in trying to be
perfect they come with that perfect
first step you're doing the biggest sin
of all which is not doing anything
sometimes you need to slow down the
speed up sometimes you need to take a
pause you need to take it easy you need
to take a step back from what you have
been doing to say well what do I want
and does this still serve me is this
still the life that I want to be
building am I still
building something that I'm I'm happy
with
or not and this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle because we are
very goal oriented right raise your hand
if you're goal oriented is that you
you've got goals you want to go off and
accomplish them we're Achievers and
Achievers get their self-worth and
self-value from hitting their goals and
checking the things off their Alyssa see
I did that I accomplished that
when people ask me what my 10-year goal
for myself is that I don't know
how are you supposed to know what what
you're going to look like in 10 years
think about who you were 10 years ago do
do this as a quick exercise think of who
you were 10 years ago who were you 10
years ago
what were your goals what were your
aspirations what your Ambitions what
your dreams
could you with any certainty with any
degree of certainty predict that you're
going to be here 10 years later
if the you from 10 years ago is making a
10-year plan for yourself is this where
you would end up
probably not no right not if you're
growing not if you're learning not if
you're improving not if you're watching
channels like this and you're investing
into yourself
the idea that you would be here is crazy
because a lot of the stuff didn't exist
and because you've you've grown and
learned yourself and so there's nothing
wrong with having plans I think they're
great I think having goals speak to your
Ambitions but you have to be willing to
jump off course when it no longer serves
you
the danger of having a 10-year goal for
yourself is your thinking small
anybody who has tenure goals for
themselves are thinking small because
you have no idea what you're capable of
in a 10-year window and you have no idea
how the world's going to change in the
next 10 years so if you could hit your
10-year goal but it's tiny compared to
what you could have done
if you're a little more flexible right
so you have to be willing to jump off
your 10-year plan
to go do something else because you're
being called to it and that's where
slowing down really helps
to get great ideas in a shower
I get great ideas in the shower we do
get great ideas on vacation I get great
ideas of vacation they get great ideas
walking through nature one of my
favorite things to do walking through
nature when I walk through
forests
just a quiet walk with the dogs
I get ideas I get great ideas I get
great ideas on drives I've started great
businesses off of different drives
I
started a business with Bo who's an
entrepreneur I invested into now it's a
mid six figure business because I was
going on a hike through the forest and
then I was driving home and it was about
an hour and a half drive and I was
reflective and for some reason this is
how it comes this is why slowing down
really matters for some reason I'm
thinking about bow in the car
I may not have thought about Beau for a
couple months why am I thinking about
bow all of a sudden all of a sudden it
just comes
I want to start a business with Bo
we're going to start an agency together
where we book guests on people's shows
and now we've done that he books some of
the biggest guests in the world for my
channel he booked Mel Robbins he booked
Matthew McConaughey he booked Deepak
Chopra his book and all sorts of crazy
guests through my channel and he does it
as a service for other people
to book great guests for their shows too
and he's passionate about helping people
watch their shows and get great
conversations and build their brands and
spread an amazing message out to the
world and so we started this business
and and he quit his job
now has a mid six figure business doing
this because I went for a walk and had a
drive and then called him or sent him a
message
and that's how a lot of the great things
have happened to me in my life a lot of
the great ideas the the next Ventures
the the Innovations and the
breakthroughs come
from slowing down
the over-scheduled entrepreneur doesn't
come up with great ideas
the over-scheduled entrepreneur might be
really efficient if you jam-packed your
calendar you might be really really
really really efficient
but you really reduce your effectiveness
and so life will go through these Ebbs
and flows these ups and downs and you'll
have these moments where all you need to
do is get work done there's been there's
been many times where I don't need any
new ideas right now I just need to
execute on what I've got in front of me
many times and so being efficient really
really matters
but when you then move to a place of
obviously some friends we move some
place of creativity
where it becomes about coming up with
the next invention the next new thing
the next place that you want to go right
then then you have to be
having chunks in your time in your
calendar that you can allow yourself
that freedom
so if I look at my day my calendar where
I spend my time I like having one day
per week to be project day so Wednesdays
for me or project day where I have the
whole day to work on whatever projects I
want to work on and then Friday I call
CEO day where I get to work on the big
picture things to grow my business
and one of my favorite things to do on
Fridays when when it's not too super
freezing outside here in Canada is go
for a walk to start the day go for a
walk clear my head I've got the whole
day ahead of me to be the CEO of my
business and and ask the question what
does that look like what does being the
CEO look like what's the next version of
Evan Carmichael
and I often come up with fantastic ideas
not all the time you know sometimes you
just go for a walk and it was great to
clear your head you get some fresh air
and that's all that came from it and
sometimes you get fantastic ideas
because you took the time to slow down
and have that in your calendar
so a couple things
how do we start the how do we start to
execute and put this as part of our
regular routine because what most people
do is you wait for your life to break
before you make a change
you wait for life to get so bad that
something happens most people don't go
on a diet and fix their health until
they have a heart attack right like you
don't actually make a change until
something breaks and forces you to
change but you don't have to hit rock
bottom you don't have to be in that
negative a situation you can be a little
more proactive and slowing down allows
you to do it so a couple a couple steps
one
puts time in your calendar every week to
have a little bit of reflection it
doesn't have to be a whole day like I do
on Fridays but a walk
put a 20 minute walk a half an hour walk
it's good it's good anyway they get a
little bit of cardio it's good anyway to
get outside get some fresh air
but but book in a half an hour walk once
a week at least somewhere in your
calendar where you're not just on your
phone and you're not just stressing
about what has to get done but you have
time to actually
just be by yourself
and watch
suddenly as Solutions come to you right
so one
put that 30 minute walk somewhere in
your calendar once a week
two
pay attention to where you you don't
love the things in your life anymore
quite often there's things that we
started with and we're energizing and
enthusiastic about and we love doing and
it was filling us up with energy and
then slowly became a job
you know I think especially as
entrepreneurs we love starting things we
love we love the beginning of something
right is that you hands up is that you
you love starting something from scratch
you love building but then we don't love
maintaining we don't love keeping it we
don't love the ongoing work with it
right there's a lot of entrepreneurs and
so that's me too
and so at that point when you stop
loving as much of the day-to-day grind
on it you still love the idea of it you
still love doing a high level work
around it but you don't love doing all
of the itty bitty stuff you either have
to let that thing go
or you hire somebody to help you with it
right it's either gotten to the point
for me it's either gotten to the point
where I can now hire somebody because
it's it's gotten to the point where it's
monetizable and I'm making some money
from it maybe not huge money but enough
to bring somebody on to help with it or
I didn't it failed it's not making money
and I don't like it anymore and so you
have to drop it
and this is again where our 10-year
goals let us down because we might be
super excited by it's like okay in 10
years I'm going to build this thing up
but the actual path needs to be actually
six months in you got to jump off that
and go do something else because you
don't love it anymore and you didn't
build that big enough
so Step One is do our 30 minute once a
week walk get some get some fresh air
and some time for yourself and then step
two is think about what are some of the
things the areas in your life that
you're not happy with anymore that maybe
used to bring you value but not anymore
you don't love the process of it and how
do you start to offload it because part
of
coming up with new ideas and creativity
is unloading the things that are filling
up space in our head in our calendar and
chances are there's lots of stuff that
fills up space in here and space in your
actual calendar that don't actually
serve you anymore and maybe never did
and it's time to let them go
either just drop them
slowly pass them on to somebody else
or hire somebody to help you with it
as you build and as you grow you're
going to have to let go of things
there's a great um
example A friend of mine who started his
business he has a hard time saying no to
people you know is that that you I have
a hard time saying no to people too he's
a hard time saying no to people and as
his business built and grew and became
more successful
the demands on his time became more and
more
pressing and he had to choose okay where
is my time going to be spent and some of
the people that he used to spend time
with or some of the organizations that
he used to donate some of his time with
he couldn't do everything so now it's
time to reprioritize
and so inside of that he said well what
where do I want to be sending my time in
with whom
and he had to let some of those
organizations go
it's sad it's hard but he had to let
some people go and let some of the
organizations go because it wasn't
either the most effective use of his
time
or to the most fulfilling like there's
nothing wrong with doing volunteer work
or helping people but it's got to feel
it's got to feel fulfilling to you
and we're constantly playing that game
like where you spend your time
with whom on what projects
is the game for the rest of your life
you're just leveling up the size the
impact the amount of care the amount of
good that you can create
and so again the over-scheduled
entrepreneur is not very creative
is not coming up with life-changing
life-breaking decisions
so step one is to schedule in that time
to get out there do your walks
allow some freedom
for new things to come to you
and then step two was doing that out of
your life of where
things no longer serve you of where your
10-year plan is falling apart and needs
to be fixed so you don't wait for life
to completely break on you before you
decide to make a proactive change
forward
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there have a not procrastinate best way
I found is you create a calendar so you
create a calendar and you put in your
calendar the habits that will lead you
towards success right so you have ideas
for what you want to create amazing